i think the best thing about our company
is that we have such a good team of
breeders
um
and we're menu planning out for
a hundred years not right just right now
i got so much genetics in my hands right
now from all the breeders that we have
in-house and the ones we collaborate
with i can't treat it like beets i'll
sit down with the breeder we do a
breeding project i'm gonna pick a b c d
f g right boom i'll take these i'll tell
them just keep them release a couple a
year or whatever it is but we have so
much genetics that we're planning out
for a hundred years so
you know we're doing a really cool [ __ ]
right now where we'll film it and be
like yo
it's 20 21 i'm sitting here
it's like a mexican chocolate i did with
bodhi shout out to bodies we're going to
take this i want to drop this in 2018.
we're going to put this in tissue
culture this is the flavor profile and
if you work at cookies right now and you
you want to know why we're dropping this
this is why i like it and this is why i
want to name it and we're going to drop
in 2018 we take that footage and we put
it away so one day maybe it'll be a
hologram or one day it'll be a video
message so maybe nft that's something
right but point being is i don't want to
open up all these stores around the
world and then have no purpose or
direction no vision right like i thought
it'd be cool that we have hundreds of
stores around the globe right
when i'm dead and gone in the future
they see a video of like why we're
releasing this strain why he liked it
why why he named it what it is and it
give my my employees and my team and
whoever is running them stores [ __ ]
vision bro like have these people fired
up like
a picture if you know colonel sanders
popped up and was like yo hey guys yeah
you know like i think people at them
drives who would take their [ __ ] a lot
serious you know a lot more serious so
we're planning out and that's my main
thing is like i don't get caught up in
the numbers of what cookies do i'm
getting caught up in how do i keep this
[ __ ] sustainable for a long time i want
to be a 100 year brand i don't want to
be a brand that's right now i'm going to
be popping later